hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back I bet you didn't think I'd be
back but here I am live on the screen
baby
and if you're hearing my voice and
you're like I know that guy
I didn't do it anyway uh back with
another compliance tip of the week this
week we're talking about cmmc control SC
dot
l2-3.13.6 deny network communications
traffic by default and allow network
communications traffic by exception I.E
deny it all baby and permitted by
exception only if you're good
[Music]
all right
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist sp171 compliant stuff on
top of an already colossal workload well
I've got great news for you you found
your home here at on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance Hero Let's jump into it so
you guys know by now that I am a giant
compliance geek
I am well that's what they wrote In The
Script okay fine I'll own that I do talk
about compliance a lot so technically I
guess that makes me a compliance key
I'll own that fine I think the idea of
compliance itself is super cool and this
control is a terrific example of why and
this control like I wouldn't have
written that at all like not even like
ah compliant yeah all right whatever
I'll own it it's I'll own it I'm reading
it it must be me I must have written
this uh Hey in this control we are not
only teaching but forcing people to do
the right thing now I believe in that I
believe compliance is cool for that
maybe I did write this silly little
script uh so look uh that's the whole
point of compliance right it's to force
you to do the right thing the number one
security blunder we find and we find it
almost everywhere uh we go is that
firewalls are configured with wide open
ports guys I just oh it just kills me I
see it everywhere allowing any kind of
traffic you can imagine in and out
without detection or really any throttle
on it at all BitTorrent check check uh
malware check uh you know why because
when when traffic can flow on any port
through the firewall who's gonna stop it
nothing so worse often these ports are
left open during a pants on fire moment
to get some system like a Voiceover IP
telephone system up and running and then
they are never put back to the lockdown
status they should have been in all
along then the bad stuff happens
firewalls should always be denial permit
by exception both incoming and outgoing
if I had a dollar for every time I went
into someone's Network and their
outgoing ports were allow all or in any
any rule oh man guys go check your
firewall right now like if you're
watching this video this is your sign go
look at your firewall and go see if
you've got way more ports open than you
should meanwhile let's dive into the
assessment points on this one so we can
figure out how to make them happy uh
assassin Point number one determine if
network communications traffic is denied
by default ultimately what you're really
going to have to do is you're gonna have
to show them your firewall right so
we'll you know the SSP answer is we're
going to say implemented via firewalls
because it's really like you have to
demonstrate this to an Assessor sure
second assessment criteria is determine
if network communications traffic is
allowed by exception again that's when
you're going to specifically allow
certain traffic on certain ports and
again you really have to kind of show
that to them via the firewall a written
answer is implemented via firewalls now
if you are banging your head against the
wall and you're this deep and you just
like six to 18 months or two years into
figuring this out guys let us come and
help you in just two to three days
because at on call we work with defense
contractors just like you every day who
have had this D far's nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon it's playing more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you and I want to see you
with higher profit margins okay even if
you're not someone directly responsible
for that you can help your company do
that you're golden they're gonna love
you alright now if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
to get the links you need for help right
now
if you love the content we're putting
out here for you help us out with a big
thumbs up on that like button or even
better smash the Subscribe button to get
the latest compliance content as soon as
our compliance centers roll it out until
the next compliance tip my friends stay
safe and secure out there hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]